hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's now I have set up some acoustic
panels to help make the sound a little
less [ __ ] so it's only slightly below
garbage love I slightly above garbage
I'm sorry I can't guy keep your hair
that confused I live in garbage all the
time now comes the ultimate test five
nights at Freddy's tres which as we all
know is the most douchey of the five
nights at Freddy's maybe I don't know I
feel like that's something to make husky
alright boink boink okay push buttons
now this is gonna be the real deal
shut up okay we've got a problem right
off the bat um excuse me is that what
happened the real game gonna have to
deal with this okay fine that's fine
that's all good that's all well and good
we just have a gigantic problem Oh big
big big big problem okay wait wait wait
wait
[ __ ] interesting oh wait oh oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh god oh god oh oh whoo that is
the worst thing I've ever seen in my
life oh my god oh my god oh my god oh oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
oh my [ __ ] god are you kidding me Wow
oh my god
Oh holy holy [ __ ]
okay oh my god oh hey whoa I can't
breathe oh wait wait wait wait hey wait
thank you here boy can you shut up for a
second oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god holy crap okay um this is
officially the worst thing I've ever
seen in my life
Oh oh my god there's a frickin vent why
didn't it I mean it never registered
that there was a frickin vent there I
mean of course it's been there that
makes total utter sense of course this
event there why wouldn't there be a vent
that but I hate that things I'm back
there
oh my god if I don't get them on now a
minute yeah I'm dead if I don't get him
where is he
see even in on the first night is he
gonna be in on the first night oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god okay nights
almost over ah hey hey oh that
that that is a tool of death that's just
a tube of death Boxey cause cooler is
this beer hope so
Wow I'm gonna die now okay there we go
why do I have to sit directly adjacent
to the tube of death like you much like
you why do you sit in this doorway of
death and you and whoever else and I
don't understand anything that's
happening I don't know okay alright
let's go for it
ah okay God shut up I just I don't have
time to deal with your shenanigans
there's secrets to fly man okay okay I
get it I get it I'm in a pizzeria but
you oh you suck [ __ ] haha like oh I I
got my eyes on you I got my eye on you
okay you're not gonna get away from me
this time
oh where are you going I see you over
there you gonna try to get in the bed
well you can't cuz that Ben is blocked
that bed is blocked
yo jobra death ain't no tube of death
it's the triple life okay
alright he's still there which is fine
so long as I could see him the [ __ ]
[ __ ] dunk of Zack what was that
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
cable get out of here [ __ ]
coin yeah oh [ __ ] where's oh I see you
know don't try it okay
that's still locked that's so close no
one's gonna die secret [ __ ] light you
okay
nope are you going yeah
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are those things what did
they put someone else in here what the
[ __ ] where you going where'd you go oh I
see you oh I see you okay who the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] not today
oh not today I see you oh I see you and
I don't like you but I see you okay
we're good everybody hold on to your
hats because this is gonna be a bumpy
ride
um but that guy I remember playing this
game and I was like ah just one you know
just want it in a wear it oh there you
are okay you ain't oh you ain't what do
you think oh you think
wait no stop wait what [ __ ] Sorry Sorry
I get it now I remember that that's the
UH there's some ah there's a buff there
there's a buffet of death raining down
upon me but I remember that I remember
very stately that uh oh [ __ ]
were you wait where are you wait wait
okay oh no oh no no no no no wait wait
no wait I'll go back go ahead hi hello
go back go back go back go back go back
pretty good did he go back oh he's going
back so I just got drawn back back back
back back back back
that green ass oh don't you go back you
ain't gonna come down this way no mo
block you shitlord up like a drum why is
he not moving he would normally be
moving in this circumstance but he's not
gonna get that gate that's for sure
I've rebooted all okay it's fine um he's
he probably went forward again so I'm
gonna just blindly assumed if I'm
keeping him five I think the strategy
are oh hi buddy okay uh well that's a
bug okay but this is good so if I can
force him back here if I can force him
back Dan everything's gonna be
hunky-dory Oh everything's gonna be
hunky-dory yeah yeah what you going you
going back oh [ __ ] he's not going back
oh [ __ ] where to go wait no deserve it
wait where is he oh wait a minute wait a
minute whoa Lee nope nope there we go
okay
again why did I look again white why did
I look again I don't know why I looked
again hi hello ha [ __ ]
Oh God look dotty be gone after the
first stop [ __ ]
that was a bang wait wait wait wait he's
in it I was that bad [ __ ] this [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] there's the horse that's the
worst that's the worst thing I'm gonna
hide under this table for a little bit
that's the worst thing I've ever done
that is the worst thing that's the worst
thing with this fist I do declare that
was the worst thing I've ever done all
right
okay all right good great this is great
I got a coin which is good no I'm
paranoid now cuz I think I'm safe
anywhere hey you know what you get a few
sucker punches to the tank a blink blink
blink
hooray huzzah oh my god we still rolling
yeah we are
oh yeah we are oh yeah we are
so let's you know let's keep the gravy
train moving baby let's go right back
into it just the worst I can't overstate
how much this is the worst
I forgive touch these
I don't like this this room
I have a funny feeling they're gonna
[ __ ] with me in this room I'm good I'm
good though I'm oh [ __ ] too close okay
all right yeah what up I don't care go
away what was that oh wait wait a minute
whoa hey wait wait go what are we put
under what happened where are you where
did you go
wait wait wait wait that's too close oh
god oh god [ __ ] me [ __ ] me screw it
go over there oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me oh
go away huh musica I can't see how about
dead am i dead why am i blind help
somebody help
did that guy
why nothing
okay nothing gonna oh [ __ ] [ __ ] why am i
why am i blind I keep going blind
keep going blind the oculus frankeour am
i he broke oh I think it broke did it
break am I am I broke the cable hookup
broke come on what happened I'm blind I
can't see can you guys see okay so I'm
still playing guys alright this is
terrible okay it's looking at me isn't
it I just whoa what did I do okay don't
okay there's still plenty what do I see
I think I see something but I'm seeing
like a barely something did I like fall
through the floor why what why can't I
saw well big so you're just [ __ ] with
me oh so you're just [ __ ] with me is
that to be understood
you you're just [ __ ] with me it's oh
you are just [ __ ] with me there I
can't see anything hey buddy listen okay
I'm Gina
[Music]
okay
let's try it again cuz why not
maybe I'll go blind again audio davon oh
no no no no no no no god damn it
Oh fiddle-dee-dee leave it leave it
leave it leave it leave it on my table
there's my fiddle fiddle I can't do that
anymore that's fine cuz I'm fine because
everything is fine it is he's gonna get
over here I know it I know it I feel it
oh is he somewhere in here where who
Darius wait he's right there that's good
okay um but what no I'm not looking at
you no I'm not you know what you know
I'm not looking at you I'm not okay so
you're not gonna be there so you're
gonna stay right there
you're not real you're not real we're
not real you're a figment of my
imagination if you're a figment of my
amendment man
no please I think I rebooted oh please
don't go blind forever
I just want to don't I just want not to
go blind forever where'd you go buddy
buddy buddy
[Music]
all right buddy buddy buddy Oh anybody
weird to go play oh you're right there
buddy
that's okay buddy over here buddy hey
come on oh there you are buddy okay hey
buddy how you doing buddy hey buddy
that's good to see you buddy hey how you
doing buddy hey listen buddy I don't
like being in this situation buddy but I
don't think you do either so maybe we
can just reason with each other and try
to get our understanding going between
us buddy so if we're just buddy buddy
about this then no one's gonna be a
problem about anything for nobody for
nothing
yeah where you going hey no stick around
buddy hey I've got more stories to tell
buddy
hey listen buddy
that's okay that's okay yeah yeah peak
over there what was that over there that
was weird that sure was weird you should
you heard a noise and there definitely
was a noise over there so why not check
that out that's a good call on you know
where to go where to go
Oh keys in there okay put that down
there so I'm gonna track Kong back here
that's okay if he goes over there that's
fine I don't mind that my buddy goes
where am i but he wants to go where my
buddy wants to go is go over there but
if he's not there oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] is he in the bed in the bank
where's I don't know where he's pretty
go where'd he go where where did he go
he's going [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh he's right
there
I see you buddy hey buddy how you doing
buddy hey it's good to see you buddy
listen I see you in the corner over
there buddy let's get a little touchy
buddy that's good because my buddy buddy
we ain't got no problems hey where you
going buddy going down here hey buddy
hey buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy listen buddy you ain't got I have
no problem with me fine got no problem
with you and I'm blind but that's okay
buddy okay buddy buddy go over there
buddy buddy it's gonna be real bit it
seems like two of these gates are closed
which is kind of a boon for me it's a
little bit of a boon I like boons boons
are good can you pull it over there
please I mean like really
okay yeah yeah yeah that was weird huh
that was weird that was a weird sound
you know weird about that okay all right
we're good anybody buddy how you doing
buddy good to see you buddy how do you
being buddy good buddy no I'm not
looking you're not real I don't care
you're not real I don't care about what
you you're looking at me okay
where'd you go buddy hey listen buddy
what are you doing what are you doing
buddy I got this solo pretty good okay
you're over I think I got this locked up
I think I do I think so long as I yeah
he's coming back so long second I'm
bouncing between these two he's he's
pretty okay that's the thing [ __ ] it
[ __ ] life if I got him bouncing
between the two I'm relatively okay so
long as they do that what does that do I
don't know what that does I don't touch
it look like an on/off switch so why
would I want to press the on/off switch
[Music]
okay all right all right good good
that's good that's very good
good good good hey Wow disappointment
all right are you - are you tired of
intrusive flavor and texture in your
food do eat a home-cooked meal and feel
silent dread well boy do we have a snack
for you this point is neither new nor
exciting
not a single remarkable flavor will
intrude on your food experience wow so
take a somber unfulfilled breath of
relief as you take a bite out of
disappointment this snack is not great
it's not even good it is boring mild and
passable and apparently 850 calories
great it's look it's got 22 percent of
your recommended fat that's wonderful I
love that oh thank you okay you've been
surprisingly absent mr. rabbit
been a little bit on the on the not here
ish miss which you know is a different
experience than what I'm used to okay so
I've got this on lock the shock factor
is over so now all that comes by is just
me playing the game the way I know how
you know you can shut your face
I'm gonna keep it on reboot all we're
gonna look for you you're right here
come over here I'm gonna close that one
and that one maybe if I can close
multiple [ __ ] gods
so hold your tits please where are you
wait we're together
wait oh where to go wait wait I can't
see can I see can I see can I see ready
to you did you go in here wait
we're to do wait Rizzy wait where do you
go
wait wait where'd he go where'd he go
he's gone oh god where are you I don't
know what what what what happened no no
what happened was that boy sir what
happened
no no no no wait hang on stop you don't
want to do this listen I may be a good
boy I've been a good boy please I've
been such a good boy
don't do it No hi we're gonna go you're
gonna go nowhere you got done why is it
dirt no no no oh the ventilation okay
it's fine it's fine
okay so if it goes slightly dark then
that's fine we're fine
hey listen hey there you are see you
ain't going nowhere you ain't going
nowhere you ain't doing nothing going
nothing going okay I've got this unlock
if I just stay calm and collected if I
stay calm and collected yeah reboot
preemptively because there's no vents
down there yeah wanna come back out here
yeah come on back there's no fence over
there you don't want to be there anyway
it's dirty it's getting dark I don't
know why
but it's getting dark it's gonna
preemptively do that okay you're going
over there now coming up here I'm gonna
run you in a circle I think business
crap that I had to beat the final load
of this one anyway so let's keep it
rolling come on my eyeballs but I'm fine
I worry about me yeah there you go
hey go who are you gonna go it's dark
fix it please fix it fits come on I'm
playing with you no you don't know what
oh [ __ ] off with you foxy Oh screw you
foxy man hooky boy that's right keep
bouncing bouncing keep bouncing no I
know there's something over there okay
there's not anything in there okay
there's nothing yes why that's what I
thought okay that's what I thought
mister man I don't know where you are
any book I don't know where he is I
can't I couldn't see oh [ __ ] okay why
are you over there I don't know I don't
think so I don't think that there's one
can you fix okay there's no fan over
there that's fine along here there's
gonna be risky it's gonna be risky but
I'm gonna try to call them
I was all right now just pissed off now
you brought the Thunder now you brought
the guns now you're gonna get it oh
you're gonna get it now
oh you try oh you try on me oh you suck
back oh you didn't like that oh that's
fine cuz that's all closed up
that's all closed up what is stupid yeah
don't you just try to dump in there huh
weird huh about that boom stupid idiot
yeah stupid fool yeah what are you gonna
do nothing oh hey do nothing yeah you
stupid yeah try going in there again it
is easier than I thought it'd be I think
I found the exploit here yes guys so
dumb he's got no brain inside there the
spring-locks done scoop your brains out
did you lose all your smarts and the
scooping room you're stupid yeah fine oh
yeah where you going nowhere dummy I
can't believe he's just died okay I
can't believe he's just that dumb
where'd it go home
[Music]
hey listen I was just joshing about all
those jokes before come back over here
hey hey buddy
hey buddy hey buddy hey hey buddy buddy
you want to come back there come back
there yeah yeah oh yeah you stupid oh
you stupid maybe try the vent again you
big dumb idiot oh you big tooth big on
stupid [ __ ] oh you full of bolts up
inside that head of uses oh okay we're
not joking around here alright we're
fine we're fine hello
maybe I am joking because this guy's a
clown or anyway over there okay good hey
why don't you go back
hey why don't you go back let's go back
yeah you want to go back
come on you want to go back so scary
down there Thanks so scary oh you stupid
oh you can stupid from this I'm too
smart for you all right give me a secret
oh here we go yes hahaha I kicked your
ass I kicked your ass with my big brain
and you're too stupid to figure out how
stupid you are
give me my prize bully I love him
oh wait no I don't love it wait what is
that wait what the [ __ ] wait no I don't
I don't I don't love that
wait why I okay I don't love this at all
that's good but you ain't so tough now
that you small huh oh no not the fist of
doom oh I'm sorry this is the fist of
the month the other fist the fist of
doom this is the fist of justice no
please not like this no please it's too
late for you scoop poop dead gone well I
win you lose stupid loser now that
everybody see me play with doll are you
having fun yes that's great to hear is
that all you had to say because that
wasn't as great to hear can you help me
know if that is what you're saying but
no okay so anyway that is all for this
episode of 5 nice if ROM B's I imagine
any more aggressive difficulty on that
like an actual 20 mode would be a
nightmare because I doubt you can
control them with that tactic like that
so yeah I'm glad that that didn't do
what it was but anyway so thank you
everybody so much for watching there's
gonna be more five nights at Freddy's VR
very soon I'm getting better at it and
there's a few more new game modes to
plow through and then if there is a
final hard mode I will address that as
it comes by but each of these coming
into
without knowing exactly what to do is
terrifying and I love it this is a
really really good game let alone being
one of the better VR games that I've
ever seen so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the more five
nights at Freddy's stuff I have in the
description from other games to fan-made
games to animations and stuff like that
so thank you everybody so much and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]